[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
star wars battlefront 2 had its final
update recently
to commemorate this and to celebrate its
arrival on ps plus we're going to check
out its secrets
from a loot box pay to win minefield to
a cherished multiplayer masterpiece
brimming with content now's the time to
jump back in and look at 25
secrets easter eggs and references to
the movies
we are starting with the final secret
added to battlefront 2 and the most
complicated unlockable you'll encounter
which is rey's resilient skin by the way
for this to work you'll need to be in a
co-op mission at mazzy's castle on
takodana you'll find this graffiti on
the side of the building which we need
to translate but don't worry
i got you it reads the pirate is hiding
something
if you know this map you'll know inside
the castle is a painting of the infamous
pirate
hondo anaka now simply shoot the
painting to receive
this token grab it and run over to jango
fett's ship
in the wooded cove listen up when you
arrive for this
sound we stop the first order assault
here close by you'll find three
interactable buttons
here's the order you need to press them
left right
center if everything's running to plan a
coin noise will sound about
now suddenly three lights will have
turned on above the tents in front of
you and they flash differently
five flashes on the left none in the
middle and one on the right
so the code here is 501 this is a nod to
the 501st legion
and if you're not a star wars mega nerd
don't worry i'll help you out
run back into mazzy's castle and you'll
spot a whole bunch of flags
the five of first one is in there
somewhere that's the one just there
now we simply need to stand on that
flagpole easier said than done
follow where i jump off if you're
struggling and once you're on that flag
turn around and you'll see a button in
the wall which can be interacted with
push it now just like ray did on the
silver screen go into the basement
and you'll be able to open the room
where she found luke's lightsaber look
that's the box there
and at this moment you'll also receive
the unlockable skin but that's not it
there's one more easter egg in here
look around and you'll see this painting
it's not just any painting
this is the team that created this game
over the last three years
forever immortalized in video game form
a brilliantly long easter egg with tons
of movie and lore references
and a touching payoff and unlockable
skin simply brilliant
[Music]
unsurprisingly given how lovingly
designed so many of them are
the multiplayer maps contain a bunch of
secrets and easter eggs
of their own head into the cantina on
mos eisley and you can activate
the infamous cantina band sure it's only
a hologram
but i wouldn't want to play a show in
the middle of a war would you in the
generator room map for the heroes and
villains mode you can see where darth
maul's iconic battle with obi-wan kenobi
and qui-gon jinn
took place at the end of the phantom
menace unfortunately you can't get very
close to those red doors and qui-gon
jinn isn't even a playable character in
battlefront 2 which means you can't
recreate that amazing scene
sometimes bro how about a few more
iconic movie locations that have been
squeezed and hidden into maps
on the yavin 4 map you can find the
death star briefing room
from a new hope while over on the
starkiller base map you might stumble
across the interrogation room
where kylo ren held rey in the force
awakens
by the way in the film the stormtrooper
that she overwhelms is actually daniel
craig
yeah james bond in star wars confirmed
oh and back to takadana look out for the
millennium falcon you can't get very
close to it but it's pretty damn cool
now let's check out the solo campaign as
it's full of references easter eggs
and nods to the wider star wars universe
seriously the amount of effort the
writers put into
linking almost every story beat to
another movie book
comic book or game is just ridiculous so
let's dive in
in the game's opening moments during the
mission the cleaner aiden escapes the
clutches of her captors
with the help of her id10 droid in fact
it's id10's
awesome eavesdropping skills that give
us our first tidbits of canonical
content
while in the ship's ventilation system
we not only hear the voice of legendary
characters admiral akbar and lando
calrissian but also the corona squad
you may not have heard of this group of
starfighters but they were actually
present during the battle of hoth
don't get me started on why that planet
should be called
while also being the group to first
learn of the construction of the second
death star
as we learned in the novel lost stars
anyway before we leave the ship aiden
actually makes her way through an
alliance briefing room where we see a
hollow projection of admiral akbar yeah
it's a trap dude to a normal person like
you and i he's outlining the plan of
operation yellow moon
and yellow moon is actually a mission
undertaken by princess leia herself
before the battle of endor again in
another novel
called moving target slightly later on
after ayden and her squad witnessed the
destruction of the second death star
from endor
the empire are working on a new plan
courtesy of a creepy interaction with
one of the late emperor's messenger
droids we learn of the dead leader's
final command
the immediate beginning of operation
cinder this is where a metric ton of
star wars stories came together in a
particularly spectacular way
operation cinder first appeared in the
shattered empire mini-series of comics
and was a back-up plan that emperor
palpatine devised to ravage the planets
should he ever be killed the idea was to
use a series of satellites that were in
orbit around those planets
to create extreme forms of weather like
electrical storms to leave them in ruin
what's really cool here is that lots of
the dialogue is directly taken word for
word
from those comics operation cinder
is to begin at once resistance
rebellion defiance
now i need to throw out a spoiler
warning here's a major twist in
battlefront 2 story so go away now if
you don't want it spoiling
go on get lost things get really
interesting when aiden and her partner
in crime delmico
defect from the empire and aid the
efforts of the rebel fleet
in actually preventing the efforts of
operation cinder as the satellites
target the planet of naboo
dell and iden join their new comrades in
attacking those satellites
trying to protect the planet they are
not alone in their efforts
see those three yellow n1 star fighters
those are piloted by
none other than leia queens aruna of
naboo and sharabay
the mother of poe dameron oh and
speaking of idon's defection
while you're on the mission the storm
keep an ear out for this
trooper who can't help but make
reference to the brilliant rpg
near ottawa
for those who are wondering 2b and 9s
are the names of the protagonists in
that game which puts this one beyond the
realms of coincidence for me
okay so we've taken a closer look at
ayden's story and it's ties to all
things star wars but she's not the only
star of the show in battlefront 2's
campaign
other legendary characters like luke
skywalker and han solo
also get their time in the spotlight and
both sequences feature some pretty cool
moments too
like this scene inside one of
palpatine's vaults on paleo where luke
and dale come across a compass which
luke seems pretty adamant on keeping i'd
like to keep this compass
if you don't mind while this compass is
a surprisingly important item in star
wars terms
i'd be pretty impressed if anyone
actually recognized it at first glance
that's because it doesn't really show up
again until the movie the last jedi
where it can be briefly seen inside
luke's hut
in fact some people have speculated that
it's the compass itself that led luke
to akto as for hands misadventures on
takodana
during the mission general distress well
let's just say the whole level feels
like one big easter egg everywhere you
go you'll be hit over the face with
references and nods
so let's try and rattle through them
quickly shall we han bumps into an old
friend who discusses a job
that has connections to the zerka
corporation after you left me stranded
during the circuit job
not a chance a galaxy spanning
manufacturer of droids and weapons best
known for their part in the star wars
game
knight of the old republic which is
brilliant by the way and solves its
sequel
we hear references made to a bunch of
different drinks on the way
out of takadana too including port in
the storm
a wine from the planet of pamath
huttslayer splash a beverage which seems
to get its name from princess leia's
um you know ability to slay huts and
finally merizane gold an amber alcoholic
drink seen throughout the galaxy
he can afford to drink marin zane gold
must be nice right
there are also a few references you can
pick up from various conversations han
can linger around to hear
this pair of characters talk about a
purple wookie
with green eyes which is probably
someone misidentifying a lasset from the
planet lyrasan
big green eyes and he was sort of purple
based on battlefront 2's place in the
timeline this is likely zeborelios from
the star wars rebels series but you guys
might be more familiar with another
lassa the jedi master giarro to paul
who was instrumental in the training of
his padawan calcestus
the protagonist from jedi fallen order
that was a heavy reference but we got
there in the end here we overhear
mention of an individual named galius
rax who first appeared in the aftermath
book series particularly for one
gentleman
name of rax if you know it rax was also
the commander of the ravager the
executor class star dreadnought that
crashed on jakku
only for rey finn and bb-8 to fly the
goddamn millennium falcon
threw it whilst invading the first order
in the force awakens
another conversation han can overhear
makes mention of the black
sun still moving cargo for black sun a
powerful crime syndicate that first
appeared in shadow of the empire the
classic n64 game
from 1996. oh my word i still remember
that game i hate being all so much
and how about one more for good luck
before you take han over to his
conversation with paldora hang around a
little to hear the latter's attempt
had a bit of wookie speak i promise you
it's so worth it
see i wasn't messing around when i said
hans time on takadana was basically a
guided tour through the furthest reaches
of the star wars universe and its law
even his completely bizarre beard is a
kind of easter egg too
as the overgrown chin strap is another
thing referenced in the aftermath series
where han travels around with his other
furry companion chewie in fact one of
the only major easter eggs that han
doesn't get in this part of the game
is his famous quote i have a bad feeling
about this han may get to proclaim this
line in a new hope
return of the jedi and the force awakens
but in battlefront 2
he'll leave this honor to our friend
lando carissian who puts his own spin on
it for good measure
you have a bad feeling about this i'd be
worried if you didn't
as we push on through the rest of the
story we get to see levels that fans of
the recent movies may recognize
of course there's the famous battle of
jakku where idon hears a whole bunch of
radio chatter that ties into other star
wars stories including the phantom
squadron
fan favorite character snap wexley and
even the lost star's own
thane kyrell phantom squadron inbound on
the empire's ground defenses wedge
snap take out those cannons and keep us
clear in the stars when dell and idon
are flying through bespin they discuss
what they're gonna do
after all this is put to bed dale
mentions visiting the planets lothal and
mike happo which are both very important
locations in star wars rebels
i thought i might travel see the galaxy
you've been to those places then there's
the campaign's epilogue
where we find out that del meko was
actually a scary
short trooper working on the same
beaches that would host the amazing
battle
at the end of the brilliant rogue one
don't bother re-watching the scene to
look for him though
dell's time on scarif was over long
before the movie was set
finally let's put a bow on the campaign
by looking at two quick easter eggs that
pop up in the resurrection expansion
which was released shortly after
battlefront 2 hit star shelves during
these missions aiden finds out about
project resurrection
a stormtrooper recruitment program
that's being operated by the first order
in these conversations we learn that the
programme is partly taking place
in the ottoman system which is the home
of sisters paige and rose tico from the
last jedi and rise of skywalker in fact
rose even mentions the presence of the
first order on her planet while she's
hanging out at canto bight with finn
during the last jedi that being said i
won't judge you if you're not keen on
going back to rewatch that portion of
the movie it was
pretty pointless later at the end of
this mini campaign aiden discovers the
schematics for a first order dreadnought
and promptly delivers it to the
resistance to give them the upper hand
then what do you see in the last jedi
paul dameron executes an
unexpected strategy when the resistance
later comes up against a dreadnought
leading to its final demise coincidence
i very much doubt it
star wars enough for you no well
how about a good old wilhelm screen to
make it better
there you go everything's better so
that's the campaign done and dusted then
don't worry you can breathe now
i don't know about you but when i see
the credits roll at the end of the game
i can't help myself but jump into the
list of trophies to see which ones i
picked up along the way
if you end up doing this in battlefront
2 keep an eye out for a few more
references
including a trophy named dark forces
another shout out to a classic star wars
video game
so there we have it 25 easter egg
secrets and hardcore nods to star wars
culture and law if i missed anything
please whack it down in the comments
below and i'll give you a heart to get
you noticed i'm adam from playstation
grenade live long and prosper
see ya